et puisque nous en sommes à la poire
passons donc au fromage et plus
précisément au camembert lors du
concours du plus gros mangeur de ce
produit le jeu est simple il faut manger
le plus possible de camembert en un
quart d'heure et pour seules armes dans
ce combat une bouteille de cidre peu
importe la manière il faut enfourner un
jeu que marie harel la créatrice du
camembert n'aurait certes pas désavoué
pour la petite histoire sachez que c'est
un certain maurice ronet pas l'acteur un
autre qui a gagné ce concours en un
quart d'heure il a avalé trois camembert
trois quarts monsieur rooney est du
reste un habitué de ce genre de concours
si l'on en juge par son palmarès plus
gros mangeur de boudin à mortagne de
kilos trip à longny au perche 31,9 du
rabroue 29 crêpes à nogent-le-rotrou 33
banane je ne sais plus où 318
d'escargots un solide appétit quoi et à
monsieur qui doit s'étonner parfois le
matin d'avoir l'estomac dans les talons